Dayna good morning California Texas and
Florida are in crisis the number of u.s.
coronavirus cases is surging to record
highs and many states are actually
reversing their reopening at the same
time the White House is trying to paint
a picture that the virus is under
control in his opening remarks at
Friday's coronavirus taskforce meeting
vice president Mike Pence looked to
assure the nation that this time is
different
we have made a truly remarkable progress
in moving our nation forward touting a
recent jobs report the vice president
said all 50 states are opening up safely
and responsibly and that the country had
flattened the curve from the initial
kovat 19 outbreak in March the reality
is we're in a much better place stay
home Harris County Texas Judge Lena
Hidalgo had a more urgent message with
hospitals in the Texas Medical Center
now reporting intensive care units 100%
full Harris County is reimposing stay at
home orders our situation is far worse
today than when we issued the first stay
home order in Harris County and when the
state issued their first day home order
this is unacceptable
Texas reported more than 5100 kovat
patients are currently hospitalized
another record high for the 15th
consecutive day on Friday Texas governor
Greg Abbott ordered bars across the
state to close again there in
environment he now says Stokes the virus
if I could go back and redo anything it
probably would have been to slow down
the opening of bars now seeing in the
aftermath of how quickly it's the corona
virus spread in the bar setting governor
Ron de santis announced a similar order
in Florida people want to be social they
want to interact now his state reported
nearly 9,000 new corona virus cases
that's a 62 percent increase from
Florida's previous record set earlier
this week in response miami-dade County
will close its beaches next Friday ahead
of the fourth of July weekend thirty-one
states have reported a jump in cases
compared to two weeks ago
Delaware Maine and New Mexico are among
the
latest to scale back reopening as the
virus continues to spread throughout the
Sunbelt the White House Task Force is
imploring everyone to play their parts
we can be either part of the solution or
part of the problem and late Friday a
federal judge ordered that ice release
124 migrant children being held in
custody over concerns they could catch
coronavirus thousands of ice detainees
have already caught the virus the
government has been given three weeks to
release those children ice has yet to
respond Michelle all right Michael thank
you so much